PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Are you looking
to optimize
application capacity?
STEPHANIE WONG: Amongst
all the other things,
global load balancing is
definitely one to check out.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, stay tuned
to learn more in this episode
of "Get Cooking In Cloud."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Last time, we talked
about load balancing
on GCP, including HTTPS
and network load balancing.
There are a lot of ways
to setup a load balancer
and back end instances
to support something
like Beyond Treat's
growing e-commerce website.
STEPHANIE WONG: They've
become a national hit
and need to start scaling
their website back
ends to meet demand.
One thing to highlight
is GCP's compute engine
manage instance groups to
take advantage of auto scaling
capabilities.
This lets you
automatically add or delete
instances from a
managed instance group
based on increases
or decreases in load.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Auto
scaling helps your applications
gracefully handle
increase in traffic
and reduce cost when the
need for resources is lower.
You define the
auto scaling policy
and the auto scaler
performs automatic scaling
based on the measured load.
STEPHANIE WONG: Check
out episodes 4 and 5
from season one of this series
for more on auto scaling.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: But
scaling global applications
can be challenging,
especially if you
have limited IT budgets and
unpredictable and burst-y
workloads.
You have holidays
in each country
that spikes demand for treat
orders at different times.
On Google Cloud, the
flexibility provided
by features like auto scaling
and load balancing can help.
However, auto scalers
have some limitations.
STEPHANIE WONG: There
are five major issues
that come up with auto scalers.
The most common issue
is that your auto
scaled new back end
running your website
isn't ready to serve
your traffic fast enough.
You might have
startup scripts that
need to be loaded before
VM instances are ready,
meaning traffic ends up
at existing instances
that are over capacity.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Second
issue is that some applications
cannot be auto scaled at all.
For example, databases often
have limited back end capacity.
Only a specific
number of front ends
can access a database that
doesn't scale horizontally.
STEPHANIE WONG:
The third issue is
that your VM back ends might
have too little headroom
capacity.
To account for a sudden
burst of traffic,
an auto scaler should include
ample headroom for example,
you can set the auto
scaler to go into effect
when your back end reaches
70% CPU utilization.
To save costs, you
might be tempted
to set this target
higher, like 90%.
But this can result
in scaling bottlenecks
when confronted with
bursts of traffic,
like an advertising campaign
that suddenly increases demand.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Fourth
issue is regional coders.
If you have unexpected
bursts in a region,
your resource coders
in that region
might limit the number of
instances you can scale to.
STEPHANIE WONG:
And the fifth issue
is that you might have
non-elastic licenses.
When you use licensed
software, you
might have a preset
maximum capacity.
So you might not be
able to auto scale
and run that software on more
than let's say 5 instances.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: You can
address these challenges
with GCP's global load
balancing solutions,
like HTTPS load balancing, SSL,
and TCP proxy load balancing.
First, let's walk
through a recipe
of how our global load balancers
handle bursts in traffic.
STEPHANIE WONG: As you may
know, typical load balancers
use an algorithmic approach
to distribute traffic
to back end servers.
Like round robin, where packets
are equally distributed between
all back ends regardless of the
packet source and destination.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Or
hashing, where packet flows
are identified based on
hashes of traffic information,
including source IP, destination
IP, port, and protocol.
All traffic that produces
the same hash value
flows to the same back end.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Today, we're going
to focus on Google's
global HTTPS load balancer
for layer 4 HTTP
or HTTPS traffic.
Typical HTTPS load balancers
use a DNS-based algorithm
serving to different load
balancers in each region.
Failover to another
region is possible,
but it can take
minutes based on time
to live or TTL configurations.
Generally, a small
amount of traffic
is still directed to old
servers well past the TTL.
This makes it not ideal
for burst-y loads.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
GCP's global HTTPS
a load balancer uses
a different approach.
Traffic is proxied through the
Google front end or GFE servers
deployed throughout most of the
global network edge locations.
Then the load balancer algorithm
is applied at GFE servers.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Here's how it works.
The HTTPS load balancer
uses a special algorithm
called waterfall by region.
Traffic that goes through
the load balancer IP address
is sent through a proxy
to the back end instances.
The algorithm determines
an optimal back end
by taking into account the
proximity of the instances
to the users, the incoming
load, and the available capacity
of the back ends in
each region and zone.
The load balancer then
distributes traffic
based on available instances.
To add new instances
based on the load,
the algorithm works
in conjunction
with auto scaling
instance groups.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
Let's walk through
some scenarios
when Beyond Treat's
traffic load becomes
too much for its
managed instance
group to handle in one region.
First, let's talk about the
traffic flow in one region.
Under normal
circumstances, all traffic
is sent to the region
closest to the user.
Then the following happens.
Traffic is distributed
across instance groups,
which can be in multiple zones.
If capacity is
unequal between zones,
zones are loaded in proportion
to their available serving
capacity.
Within zones, requests
are spread evenly
over the instances in
each instance group.
STEPHANIE WONG: If an entire
region reaches capacity
because the capacity limits you
assigned to an instance group,
the waterfall by region
algorithm is triggered
and traffic overflows to
the next closest region that
has available capacity.
As each region reaches
capacity, traffic
spills over to the next
closest region, and so on.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Let's say
you have unhealthy back ends
and you need cross
regional overflow.
If the health check
sees more than half
of the back ends in the
region are unhealthy,
the GFE servers preemptively
overflows some traffic
to the next closest region.
That way you don't have
an entire region failing
as the region becomes unhealthy.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
Now let's say all the regions
you have instance groups in
are above capacity.
Traffic is then
balanced so every region
is at the same relative
level of overflow
compared to its capacity.
For example, if global demand
exceeds global capacity by 20%,
traffic is distributed so that
all regions receive requests
at 20% over regional capacity
while keeping traffic
as local as possible.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
how does using HTTPS load
balancing actually address
the five capacity challenges
we talked about
in the beginning.
STEPHANIE WONG: Let's see how.
Now that we've discussed how
the GFE and waterfall by region
algorithm works, the HTTPS TCP
proxy and the SSL proxy load
balancers can overflow
capacity to other regions.
This means that it's a good
idea to use a global load
balancer over the regional load
balancers, especially when it
comes to global e-commerce
sites like Beyond Treat.
Apps that use regional back ends
have nominally lower latency,
but they can become
overloaded very easily.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: For latency
in starting new instances,
if the auto scaler cannot add
capacity fast enough during
bursts, the HTTPS load balancer
will temporarily overflow
connections to the
next closest region.
As soon as back end
instances are scaled up
in the original
region, new traffic
is routed to region
closest to the users again.
STEPHANIE WONG: For apps like
databases limited by back end
capacity, you can
still overflow traffic
to the next closest region
when demand in one region
is beyond capacity deployed
for usual traffic needs.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: As for
too little VM headroom,
regional overflow
still saves money
because you can either setup
auto scaling with a high CPU
usage trigger, or make back end
capacity well under a region's
capacity since overflow
to other regions
ensure global capacity
will always be sufficient.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now
for regional quotas,
if compute engine resource
quotas don't match demand,
load balancing overflow
automatically redirects
part of the traffic to a
region that can still scale
within its regional quota.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: In
the case of licenses,
the load balancer can
move traffic to a region
where licenses are available.
You just set the maximum
number of instances to the same
as the maximum number of
licenses on the auto scaler.
STEPHANIE WONG: It's
key to point out
that you do need a set
up and manage instance
groups in the regions you feel
are appropriate for your user
base.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
You have to also take
into account things like app
licenses and dependencies
like database scaling to
meet the demand of auto
scaled website servers.
STEPHANIE WONG: For
more information
about GCP's global
load balancing,
check out the solution article
by our friend, [INAUDIBLE]..
Link below.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That's all for today
on Get Cooking In Cloud.
Hopefully we were
able to intrigue you
with ingredients and
recipe to whip up
a resilient and performing
dessert site for our global fan
base.
STEPHANIE WONG: If
you liked this video
and would like to see
more of this content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]